all right former vice president Mike
Pence is revealing new details about his
work inside the Trump Administration
reflecting on his life his service his
faith leadership his new book is called
so help me God it contains fascinating
details about how his faith love her
country continues to guide him every
step of the way now earlier tonight I
sat down with the former vice president
to talk about this and much more
all right joining us now is Vice
President Mike Pence so help me God now
you can get at amazon.com hannity.com
bookstores everywhere
um
what an amazing life you've had now I
know every interview so far that you've
given only wants to talk about one topic
right and there are 50 what two chapters
in the book and maybe two or three of
the chapters deal with what
it seems the only media only wants to
talk about but there's a lot more to you
into this book
um and I think it's a disservice not to
go over a lot of it
um let's talk about this life here you
are you become the vice president of the
United States
well Sean first thanks it's great to be
with you and it was very humbling for me
to have a chance to write my life story
you know growing up the grandson of an
Irish immigrant sound familiar yeah my
mother first generation American my
father a combat veteran
big Irish Catholic Family in a small
town in Indiana dream someday of
representing my hometown in Washington
DC and to have had the privilege to have
been the congressman for my hometown the
governor my home state and to serve as
Vice President of the United States as I
write in the book is a testament
I believe that God's faithfulness in my
life the decision I made to put my faith
in Jesus Christ and it's Testament my
incredible wife Karen and our family and
their support every step of the way and
it's also a testament to the Vitality of
our ideas that whether it was my years
in Congress where I was fighting for
conservative values or or standing as a
conservative Governor you know cutting
taxes and growing the state's economy
and standing for liberty or whether it
was that remarkable four years of the
Trump Pence Administration where we took
those conservative principles that you
and I have talked about all of our lives
and we put them into practice and we we
left America stronger and more
prosperous than ever before revived our
economy rebuilt our military stood with
our allies stood up to our enemies and
of course to me the greatest
accomplishment was three Supreme Court
Justices
made our liberties more secure and gave
America A New Beginning for Life writing
about all of that and of course writing
all the way to the end and the difficult
days at the end our Administration
didn't end well but writing about those
four years is what so helped me God is
principally all about and I I my my
heart's desires that it gives people
hope and encouragement that what we did
before we can do again I always say
conservatism Works simple Liberty
Freedom capitalism our constitution
lower taxes less government and in the
case of the administration what secure
borders in the case of energy
Independence we hadn't achieved that in
forever free and fair trade peace
through strength uh constitutionalists
on the bench Law and Order so people are
safe and secure and how about a
classical education and I think we
covered most the conservatives and you
do all of those things at the same time
I'd like to say you take three steps
back and America happens I mean right
over the last two years as I've been
traveling all over the country
people have come up to me from time to
time and said you know seeing the way
things have gone down here at home it
seems like we have an Administration
that's actually intent on weakening
America at home and abroad
and people come up and say do you think
we can get it back and I I always say
we'll get it all back and you'll be
you'll be surprised how quickly it comes
back I think that's one of the things
that that we proved particularly in
those first two years of the trumpets
Administration was when you have an
Administration that knows what makes
America prosperous and strong and secure
and then you have partners and
majorities in the house and in the
Senate it's extraordinary what you can
accomplish but it all takes leadership
and I truly do believe that with the
right leadership uh in Washington DC
we'll bring it all back and then some
your reaction to the election the
overwhelming likelihood now the
Republicans have the house I think is a
big big deal
and I was not one of those people out
there saying this is going to be a red
wave I looked at those Senate Races they
are all Bellwether Estates they're all
swing States I thought they were hard I
can give you my reasons why I think
things happen here or there but the
reality is we the Republicans winning
the house albeit a small majority is a
big deal and the last election nobody
thought Republicans would pick up as
many seats as they have so well I I
think I was a little more optimistic
than you were but you turned out to be
right it was a tougher year and the
truth is we were in many ways that the
foundations were there right the truth
is we were fighting on on their Terrain
more than we were in 2010 when I was in
the House Majority and and we won 63
seats I I knew that the possibility of
winning uh at 20 or 30 seats was there
but it was going to be a challenge it
was going to be tough but all that being
said
a win is a win
I I have to tell you I was there the
last time that we fired Nancy Pelosi uh
and and I couldn't be more proud of
Kevin McCarthy and Steve's Kalise and
every single one of the rank and file
members that worked their hearts out I I
traveled to 35 States I campaigned with
a lot of house members Across America
and I want to tell you this incoming
class of freshmen is going to make
everybody proud it's it is an
extraordinary group of men and women
strong conservative principles and the
day that Nancy Pelosi hands that gavel
to speaker Kevin McCarthy's going to be
a great day for America and and if you
remember when we did before we won the
house in 2010 it would be a few more
years before we won the Senate and then
a couple years after that when we won
the White House and so this is step one
and it's an enormously important step to
be able to stop what the Biden
Administration continues to do to pile
more spending on this on the American
people and future generations and I
truly do believe whether it's the crisis
at our Southern border uh whether it be
this gusher of spending that's driving
the worst inflation in 40 years
Republicans are now going to be in a
position with the power of the purse to
drive forward policy changes and demand
policy changes that at least begin to
move our country back to prosperity and
security we'll have chairmanships
they'll have the power of the person
they'll also have the power to subpoena
and I think there's been a lot of things
that have gone uninvestigated things we
should be investigating uh this year
should that be their top priority I
don't know I would I would prefer to see
our gas prices go lower I'd prefer to
see our borders get secure I would
prefer energy Independence I don't Joe
Biden answered the question last week
what will you do differently his word
nothing right he won't do the thing well
that's it look oversights finally
important and I have every confidence
that House Republicans the right
committees will be creating that kind of
accountability but I'm with you I I
think it's important in these next two
years
that House Republicans if only passing
it in the House of Representatives
produce a a essentially a portfolio of
bills that show the American people the
way back
even if they just pile up on Chuck
Schumer's desk that we that we how do we
get the economy turned around how do we
turn off the spicket of spending that's
driving inflation how do we achieve
energy Independence as we did under the
Trump Pence Administration how do we
secure our border
I I love that Bible verse it says
without a vision the people perish I
think House Republicans have an
opportunity in the majority to pass one
bill after another that will lay out
that Vision that will remind people of
the policies of the trumpets
Administration that will confront the
challenges facing our country today and
and really lay a predicate a lay a
predicate for winning America back in
2024. let's talk a little bit about
America's election system because
to me what's going on in Arizona what's
been going on in Nevada we still have
all these California races oh 50 percent
of the vote counted 60 percent of the
vote counted Alaska we might not know
the winner until what Thanksgiving
um is it time for the country is it
better for the country I would prefer if
I could write my own election law but
every state has to do it I believe
constitutionally right but to have
same-day voting to have partisan
observers watch the vote count and then
watch the voting watch them both and we
know the results at the end of the day
what you have Great Britain doesn't
France does it Canada does he have all
these countries that paper ballots
that's what they do and Indiana does it
Indiana okay and you could make
exceptions for the sick for the affirms
people out of military people
um or people that are going to be out of
state or out of their Precinct that day
um I don't like it seems like voting for
months on end mail-in balloting right at
some point do you think the system why
can't when I say Indiana we actually we
count the votes and uh we finish the
election on Election Day
now we have we have some early voting we
have mail-in voting in the state of
Indiana there's there there's a long
tradition of that in this country but
what what's missing and it's a source of
great frustration I'm sure the people in
Arizona and California it's amazing Sean
we're sitting here a week after election
day and we are waiting on the outcome of
elections in in critical States and I I
just I hold the view that early voting
it can be managed with real integrity
and frankly we've seen election reforms
passed in states around the country that
have reinforced people's confidence in
election Integrity but for heaven's
sake's election day ought to be election
day and and we ought to we ought to be
calling everybody in every one of their
own States ought to be said you know
what we might have to stay up late on
Election Day to find out what the
results are but we can count the votes
after the polls close and tell people I
am hoping that I get some
reactions it's absolutely important
important let's let's talk a little bit
about your future
politically are you going to get back in
the arena thinking about it on the fence
where are you I could tell you Karen and
I are seriously considering
what role we might play in the future
and and including as a candidate for
public office again you know it's only
one office that I think you'd run for
well you're right and you know for us a
friend of mine said to me many years ago
there's two kinds of people in politics
people that are called and people that
are driven
and candidly as I write and so help me
God I've been both early in my political
career I allowed my ambition to get
ahead of me
I found myself caught up in campaigns
that at the end of the day I wasn't
proud of
but when the when it came back around a
decade later the year that I was elected
to congress the first time
in 2000 Karen and I had three small
children
um but we step forward on faith we
literally we we put our lives and our
careers essentially in the Lord's hands
we we ran campaigns that we could be
proud of we laid out our conservative
values and just trusted God for the
outcome and so what we'll look for in
the days ahead is is what our sense of
calling is as a family you know we have
two in the military in our immediate
family right now and and because of
deployments we actually haven't all been
together
for three years but in Indiana we'll
have the whole family back together over
the holidays we'll hear our kids out
who've always been a part of our public
life and then Karen and I will make a
decision about where we think we might
best serve but I promise to keep you
posted Sean so there are 52 chapters in
the book every interview so far you've
done up until this one you should have
done this one first
um only wants to talk about you Donald
Trump January 6th and negate what I
think before incredibly successful years
and I can go through all the
achievements you could probably list
them a lot better than me because you
were part of them I wasn't
and before really successful years
together and it culminated with a Oval
Office meeting one-on-one
with you
and the president that went on for 90
minutes or so
and to me that talks about
okay we did this together was it much
disagreement of putting this one issue
aside of January 6 was there much
disagreement in the four years that you
recall because I don't recall it well I
I have to tell you that as as different
as the two of us are
president Trump and I actually
forged a close working relationship he
was not just my president he was my
friend
and we literally spent time together
every day when we were both at the White
House sometimes up to four hours ago you
got an office I had an office in the
west wing and and found myself back and
forth from my office to the Oval Office
on a regular basis I chronicled that in
the book we had a a very a successful
relationship that obviously didn't end
well and you know I'll always believed
that I did my duty on that tragic day
under the Constitution and the laws of
this country
but in the aftermath of of those
difficult days
the president and I did sit down we
talked through it I I recount some of
that in my book
and as I told you last fall when we got
together I we parted amicably and we
spoke a number of times after I left
office but
frankly when the president returned to
some of the rhetoric about me and others
who had taken a stand for the
Constitution I thought it was best that
we just go our separate ways but
the foundation of our ability to part
amicably came from that relationship
that was forged in those four years and
and I will always be proud of the record
of the Trump Pence Administration what
we were able to do for this country I
mean if you think about it I mean Russia
never tried to redraw International
lines during our Administration that was
the only Administration in the 21st
century for which that was true we
changed the national consensus on China
President Biden meets with president
ajid today and promises more talks with
China well we we didn't just talk we
imposed 250 billion dollars in tariffs
we we strengthened our military
alliances in the region we maintained
freedom of navigation held them
accountable for intellectual property
theft
progress that we made here at home seven
million good paying jobs we cut taxes
rolled back regulations
Unleashed American Energy achieved
American Energy Independence appointed
conservatives to our Courts at every
level and and reduced illegal
immigration by 90 percent I Chronicle
how we did all of those things and we
didn't get everything done that we
wanted to get done I I write in that
first year about coming up one vote
short of repealing and replacing
Obamacare but then to see the way with
the president's leadership we rallied
back and and we cut taxes and and really
restored the strength and vitality of
this country I'm excited to tell and I'm
not I'm not I'm not assigning blame but
John McCain was the one vote in that
moment he was it was uh you know I try
and capture that
because people will read the book you've
done multiple interviews to talk about
that time that period I've known you for
all these years and going back to the
time you were a congressman and a
governor and this whole other life and
this whole book that you write and
people want to focus on the one chapter
what what percentage of the time
putting did you did you have Harmony in
this relationship because I know you
both I've known you both for years I've
known you both for 30 years
you know and I couldn't meet really or
Define two different people very
different right
um and but yet what percentage of the
time was it a perfect partnership in
terms of getting the job done I you know
I I re I recount a few moments
where we had disagreements
but I always kept those in private
you know I truly do believe in humility
and orientation to Authority and as as
vice president
I believe my role was to be there to
support the president not to be just one
more voice among A Chorus of people with
opinions
and I think that created a rapport
between us of trust and genuine
friendship it's part of what uh made
what happened at the end so difficult I
knew what my duty was under the
Constitution of the United States I I
made that clear many times over to the
president but he had he had legal
advisors around him that were telling
him something different and uh we ended
up having to have a disagreement a very
loud disagreement in public and uh
but what made that even more difficult
is because literally every step of the
way from the day I was added to the
National Ticket all the way until
election day 2020. we had a strong close
working relationship that was built on
mutual respect and it's one of the
reasons I'll always be proud of the
record of the Trump Pence Administration
we can't possibly capture the the book
but it is a comprehensive
Insider's view what it was like it is
for very historic years and uh and what
a life you've LED on top of everything
always enjoy having you Mr Vice
President thank you sir
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else